[Applaudissements]
les gars tu connaisses devenir maman
cyril balzan c'est vrai qu'il est il est
partout le gaye partenaires et ben on en
arriver là et payer gossip girl par les
mains non halal à dan carter et bush
adoration contre plusieurs sageb de
clichés longtemps j'adore camp kabyle
fait j'adore s'est rencontrés plusieurs
fois puis il a dit qu'il connaissait pas
le champ des lilas des blagues qui parle
dans cette émission vous les entendez
pas à bormio bercy il a dit aussi
rencontre aux chandelles et 10 hommes
que le combat
à l'époque est un terreau surprise hier
pour isa par quoi commence le 20 45
habituellement tous les soirs le quoi le
bas enfin le montage
bonsoir connaissez mon prénom est
l'acronyme oui pourquoi ça commence ce
soir
ta chronique ouais et bah ça commence
mal et 24 heures voilà les votes et a
bien rendu et on s'est régalé faut-il
aussi je vous le dis ce qu'il dit ou ce
soir en énerver les hameaux dit que
rappelait camille combal qui nous dit 10
paraît que vous entendez pas le plus du
tout est si rude alors sachez le c'est
mon frérot avis ans qu'on s'aime et on
voit là et on s'aimerait encore pendant
25 ans fin pour moi il reste qu'en dit
aussi que j'arrive pas de prime à venir
sont des bonnes nouvelles sections
foulée chanson cela n'aurait tout va
bien d'assurer une série policière qui
me rend dingue ou va bien ainsi on
touche à une coloc tu auras des tuvache
t1 vel satis en ligne de cou de marque
les 24 heures c'est ce qu'il fallait
voir à la télé heure par heure futur
faute toi mais très très vite
c'est pas ça marche que chardy sont ceux
gagnés tous ces barques sur dives à
regarder à midi les caméras du 12 13
regardez ils ont grillé la conductrice
qui avait déjà commencé son déjeuner
dans la voiture pas de bol bill pour
elle quand france trois films se dire
qu'il peut a anticipé de 0,2 à 0,5
secondes
donc c'est un homme à l'air de bien se
passer pour cette
ce bien à 21h dans l'amour est dans le
pré on a eu la preuve que même en zone
rurale d'internet il reçoit bien depuis
combien de temps
mais depuis je me rencontrer jackie et
michel réseau internet
l'éternel ce matin à 8h30 en donner la
preuve que vous pouvez être une banane
en sport quoi qu'il arrive votre mère
vous regardera toujours avec les yeux
d'une mère berthe et aux libyens ce
matin pour en parler le professeur
antoine baehni solo et enfin c'est tombé
ce soit à 17h matt pokora et cyril
hanouna vu un enfant ensemble il est
parti à aller avec son père on à la
photo une photo allait bien
[Applaudissements]
on a les mêmes michaud qu il a quelque
chose avec puff daddy c'est m gibbs le
il ya plein de sosies ce soir à la télé
je vous dise d'or les sosies bon vous le
savez peut-être pas mais en latin
micro-sieste jeudi des chiffres et des
lettres
quand même regardé le jeu cet après
suppression
merci d'abordage a failli être annulée
grosse tuile bertrand renard a perdu le
marque page de son dico album est dans
les définitions à le bata d'accord alors
bertrand propos popopopop au bas de
jeudi défiant isabel ii commence à
devenir un petit peu sourde à pas sûrs
que madame bintou rappel de sitôt je me
cache pas à l'affût toujours très en
tout cas là je suis prêt pour prendre un
appel
bah oui des jeunes transition bravo
c'est parti à laurent genre oui bon goût
comment vous appelez-vous elle vient
bonjour madame critot les labels des
coûts de plus non plus son coanimateur
on dirige syrie pendant une anecdote
isabelle en live position assez court
mais là ça se passait la cinémathèque
c'est juste derrière bercy est super
sympa c'est très très bien c'est une
très belle exposition
et c'est une très bonne idée ben merci
ça se passe au à la cinémathèque a
derrière merci
[Applaudissements]
j'ai regardé produits dits agité ce soir
à est allé chez nous de prendre sa thune
et que c'est benayoun qui a gagné 250 ou
alors ils osaient de tous les
chroniqueurs inhalent intronisé en
pyjama c'est virginie ecully qui me
lisent ou qui me l'ont fait bas écouter
bas se sont bien foutus de bonnes on en
penser comme cet avocat ni belle
botanique bond en tout on veut prendre
sa place si un candidat qui a raconté
une anecdote sur le festival de la bière
allemande e oktoberfest et tu sens que
nagui est pas gros clients de bien vous
êtes allé à l'octobre fils à
l'oktoberfest c'est la plus grise aux
clubbers fait ce triste c'est autre
chose
mon message au public des 12 coups de
midi prenez pas votre enfant sur les
genoux pendant le décompte sinon ça fait
treize coups en fait tu pouvais au
tennis
ouah
attention petit moment tendresse de
l'émission vous avez retenu que ça hier
donc un chien qui ne comprend pas
pourquoi il peut pas sortir de chez lui
c'est mon camp c'est ma journée
[Musique]
j'ai trop vu ses rivaux dans le futur
les images d'animaux jetant des jeunes
que pour toi dans ce bref si vous êtes à
une petite fille manon à la fin je
n'avais pas dedans franchement c'est un
rat dit cela mais comme un homme non
sans dévoiler ses détracteurs comme hat
seo perds ou tu daboub a jeté vue mais
en fait c'est pas vrai ils savent pas à
nommer un produit il essaie de se lever
aux gars de regarder ces jours ci les
[Musique]
produits polémique de sa série de
polémiques sur certains produits
je me désole au téléphone c'est bon j'ai
eu au téléphone tout inquiète pas je
sais que tu es thérapie j'en ai mieux à
sa valeur à tout à l'heure
j'adore ok là dans ces chiens peuvent à
n'importe quel moment j'ai regardé les
jt aussi ça dérange pas bien va pas me
dire demain ouest est chiante appareils
des jtc trottier jean-paul maintenant
c'est sûr donc on a regardé le 13h de
tf1 turin on connaît jean pierre pernaut
c'est le meilleur pour parler des
régions françaises mon petit pont par
les penseurs il n'arrête pas il adore ça
il cartonne c'est un carton de fou en
revanche dès qu'il faut parler des
comédies musicales de tf1 il a ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon des présentateurs
de jt une grosse flemme as de ouf moins
payant et déjà donné
c'est très beau marseille 3 février
toulouse me disent et c'est la chaîne
locale 10 i télé a aussi son tp mt avec
des chroniqueurs qui sont assez directe
quand ils sont à court d'arguments
madame ou monsieur je sais pas qui vous
êtes et me donne pas un chose et je vous
dis les choses toute façon on n'aurait
pas cette cartouche et et puis écoutez
on vous emmerde matin sur ces news jean
pierre elkabbach il a fait la connerie
que ce fou de son oreillette dans n'est
pas dans l'oreille erreur classique il
entend moins bien forcément enfin
carneiro on vient d'apprendre que
françois hollande et dora l'exploratrice
au lieu à un enfant de star on a vu leur
fille à la télé sur vos partenaires pour
moi le bonheur période martin sur ces 12
a les moyens il ya kelly qui maquille
maxime a dit en loge ça fait un bail que
t'as pas parler de vous êtes formidables
sur france 3 nord oui c'est vrai que
l'entente show de françois ils ont aussi
des invités on a la chance de vous avoir
ce soir et ce matin il avait julien
annese qui bosse à amérique dunkerque et
un truc tu délires pour être tous le
faire puis l'émission avant pluie mais
les chapeaux chelou mais explique page
pas complet compte 57 sur sélectivement
ces collectors merci beaucoup pour ce
cadeau je suis bien on n'a pas de cadeau
et huile plus tard il faut faire dites
moi j'écoute
[Musique]
il m'est déjà conclus lorsque je lui
tiens hasard du calendrier c'était
l'anniversaire d'ailleurs de leurs
invités souhaite un bon anniversaire
facebook et nous aussi on vous souhaite
un bon anniversaire et est bien avec
france 3 nord c'est qu'ils savent
recevoir digne des grammy awards niveau
fiesta regardé comme si super 2000 et
qui on a retrouvé sur lcp ce matin marc
lavoine
mais visiblement ils avaient fait un peu
la fête avec jean-louis toute la nuit la
mort fait puisque beaucoup de
médicaments
[Applaudissements]
cole avait au début rafa diez barghouti
j'ai maté sopro c'est au programme
c'est allez vous parler du tour n'est
jamais l'avoir faut le talent jamais et
ce matin encore et j'ai un nouveau jeu
aussi je sais pas dit mais tu vois ce
qu'on est dans c'est au programme ils
ont balancé des sujets de ophain si ça
plait pas la direction il en a rien à
[ __ ] soso delphine tac à vivre avec
mal non plus bonjour à tous c'est tout
merci de nous rejoindre c'est un plaisir
de vous recevoir dossier extrêmement
concernant ce matin qu on dise stop à
bon nordiste pas quoi sophie stop aux
disparités de salaires entre les hommes
et les deux femmes stop aux fraudeurs
dans les métros stop originaux de jets
ont dit stop à la constipation aussi
bien sûr été un petit conseil conso
quand il pleut ça sert à rien d'arroser
votre pelouse à l'égard quand il pleut
ça sert à rien c'est bête à dire mais je
peux faire vire parfois au complet à
faire sur w9 une candidate des princes
qui a voulu hausser le niveau en parlant
d'install mot log mal aurait peut-être
pas dû
quelque chose à quoi et attention voici
les premières images des gardiens de la
galaxie 3 avec roach est notamment c'est
mon image cyril des scènes d'action à
couper le souffle
ah ouais
je voulais voir mon nouveau jeu bien sûr
j'adore le double jeu il est très simple
il ya même un jingle écouter non
[Musique]
le prince et sa vie pour une mûre pour
le principe est très simple on va voir
des gens dans la rue on part à votre
rencontre tout simplement et honda
panneaux avec trois des chroniqueurs
autour de la table dessus ça dort et
ensuite on vous demande de choisir un
pour la vie ah ouais hein seulement pour
la nuit et à qui rentre chez sa mère que
vous chelem c'est pas parce que vraiment
c'est ce que vous avez d'abord on était
là votre encore de regarder ce que ça
donne ça dort on est donc parti avec nos
pompes car présentant chacune trois
chroniqueurs gros succès pour géraldine
plus qu'à me forget il ne vous cache pas
regardé aïe aïe aïe aïe non j'aime aucun
moi non plus mais c'est aussi qu'elettra
j'aime pas ouais je la connais c'est
baba machin l'achète à quoi elle pour
une nuit et elle pour toute la vie mais
en général elles peu coquine alors
beaucoup moins castaldi c'est pas un
homme sérieux pour lui pour la vie je
pense à sera jamais pour la vie ce sera
pour une semaine sans doute je te fais
la nuit vient une cup valérie bénaïm si
ça doit être cool parce que doivent un
peu d'expérience
voilà on va changer si c'est pour une
histoire sans l'homme
justement ça va être à la toilette comme
ça qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le laisse
aux copines on le laisse faire sa pub
pour les fenêtres nous on a des grands
un peu coquine mais marié ce serait lui
pourquoi il est mignon et lui ce serait
pour une nuit c'est ça voilà parce que
les businessmans je pourrais prendre son
fric
une nuit mais ce sera peut-être pas la
meilleure nuit de ma vie c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tout fait là je faisais là